more outrage tonight following the
despicable decision to send our national
guard troops to
sleep in a cold freezing cement parking
garage
can't make this up gop house minority
leader kevin mccarthy tweeting quote
speaker pelosi majority leader schumer
why are american troops who are tasked
with keeping security at the capitol
being forced to sleep in a parking lot
they deserve to be treated with respect
we deserve answers
here with reaction he is the house
minority leader
kevin mccarthy uh i cannot believe what
i saw i think
president trump and exile to quote jim
acosta
actually said he'd offer the trump hotel
i read in different reports out there
um i read one article today i haven't
really fully confirmed it that it
actually violates the geneva conventions
for prisoners it was shameful how they
were treated
yeah you watch these men and women
defending us
it was just shameful many of them had to
be sleeping on cots for the week
very few bathrooms and others many of
the many of the congresswomen and men
were coming down bringing them
pizza and others and thanking them the
next thing you know they're
just swiffing them out the door but we
know what nancy pelosi has said about
them before remember when the riots were
happening
in washington over the summer nancy
pelosi said the national guard at the
lincoln memoir
it was scary they shouldn't be there or
in portland in july when the riots were
going on
you know what she said about dhs this
department of homeland security that
they were storm troopers
so we we see the true side of what this
speaker has um
thought of these men and women that have
been defending us
all right let me let me ask you this
because i
submit to you my belief is nancy pelosi
with the
thinnest majority you know in modern
times you would know the history better
than i
um really a speaker in name only is that
if she deviates at all from her radical
base
she'll be out she'll be replaced so
i don't think she has any real power so
to speak
but isn't she in charge of the
sergeant-at-arms
now don't we know from the chief of
police in d.c
congressman that in fact there were
multiple warnings before
during this whole thing to get the
national guard there ahead of time
i think doesn't she have explaining to
do here why didn't she have
any security the breach was 60 seconds
i believe so because this is why i've
called for a bipartisan commission kind
of like the 911
because we've got to have the answers i
am now
finding out after the fact that the fbi
knew long prior to any speech by the
president
that people had planned this and they
had conveyed this
to the sergeant of arms well i'm the
republican leader why wouldn't they have
told me as well
did they convey that to the speaker who
knew about this ahead of time
they had told us prior that they had
they had worked with the fbi they had
worked with the national guard that they
were prepared
but why did they hold that decision to
calling them up to protect this capital
they found ieds earlier in the morning
did they call the fbi or national guard
then
there are many questions that have to be
answered and it can't just fire the
sergeant of arms let's know who knew
what and when
and what decisions did they make now we
have court filings
even liberal news outlets like the
washington post and cnn
that we had intel before we didn't act
on it
and number two uh they were
they were derelict in their duty but
this was all pre-planned that's what
the washington post and fake news cnn
are reporting
so i've got to imagine uh that a lot of
people have a lot of explaining to do
knowing that there were going to be
hundreds of thousands of people in town
and that they were planning to march to
the capitol there were no preparations
whatsoever
who would you hold to account here
well that's exactly why when they talk
about why this p
impeachment is so political they did no
research on this and now after the fact
we're finding out
people knew ahead of time things were
being planned and they're
trying to make a political impeachment
on a president saying
go to the capitol peacefully demonstrate
is now
encouraging this in some way after we
had found out the fbi told them that
they had already been planning this
but again did they tell the other
members who knew this
and when and what actions were taken to
protect the capital
these are questions that have to be
answered the american public has a right
to know
all right kevin mccarthy congressman
thank you
now joining us texas governor greg
abbott he's ordering the return
of national guard troops from texas and
it's also slamming biden's dangerous
open borders amnesty agenda
that will make us the united sanctuary
states of america
writing quote president biden is trying
to halt deportations of illegal
immigrants who already have a final
order of removal
illegal aliens but reading exact words
from the u.s
this abandons the obligation to enforce
federal immigration laws
texas is fighting this attempt to grant
blanket amnesty
here with reaction texas governor greg
abbott texas
governor i i think texas interestingly
you see our our national guards are
being treated are you going to bring
them home
if they don't if they're going to be
sleeping on cold concrete
in the middle of winter in a parking
garage because they deserve better
sean these are men and women that as
governor i have deployed to
help secure our border i've deployed to
help people
overcome hurricane harvey i deploy them
in communities across texas during
protests this summer and i deploy them
to protect the texas capital itself
these are men and women who should be
respected not
denigrated they were subject to a
political correctness test
these are men and women who have served
in afghanistan and overseas and yet
there are forced to sleep in in a
parking garage
and that's why sean i have ordered our
national guard from texas
to be on the first plane back home i was
requested today
for them to be able to stay longer i
said no they should be on the first
plane back home to texas those are the
governor's orders
all right let's talk more about borders
and what it means for your state and now
that we're going to
stop construction of the wall we stop
enforcement
there's now a path to amnesty um
that i would assume puts a massive
burden on you
to protect the people of texas
well so you've been there you know texas
has the longest border
in the united states more than 1200
miles and in a way
the democrats are living up to exactly
what they said during the course of the
presidential campaign
they advocated open borders and
president biden is wasting
no time to achieve that goal and you
talked earlier about
uh what we wrote to the president
because what the president is doing is
directly violating the law let me
read you one quick short clause from
eight
usc section 1231 it says when an alien
is ordered removed the u.s attorney
general
shall remove the alien from the united
states within a period
of 90 days what biden has done is he is
ignoring
that federal law disregarding that
federal law
by ordering to the attorney general to
ignore that
or ordering department of homeland
security not to follow those orders
that is in direct contradiction of
federal law and sean
is in direct contradiction of an
agreement between the state of texas
and the united states department of
homeland security well
that again would be post-constitutional
again
but this isn't the first time this has
happened this all got started
in large part by uh it in the
former biden obama administration that
barack obama did this
so now i mean i know they've talked
about it
are there any plans to take down the new
border wall that was built
you know it's amazing because biden has
talked about
taking down this wall despite the fact
that for one
that would pose serious challenges with
regard to the open border issue that
we're
fighting back against but secondly it
would burden
taxpayers with increased tax dollars
being spent
to do something that is a valuable tool
in our ongoing fight
against immigration that is illegal and
so we want to make sure
that texas is stepping up we are already
adding
more funds to this texas state budget so
the state of texas
will be able to do a better job of
securing the border doing the job that
the president of the united states
should be doing all right governor as
always great to have you thanks for
being with us